يعني بصراحه كان الوضع جدا سيء يعني نحن
طلعنا من من غزه يعني والله مجبورين يعني
طلعنا من جمع الشفاء الطبي لانه ما ظل ولا
صحف موجود هناك الاوضاع كانت جدا سيئه
يعني انا تم تهديدي بشكل مباشر من
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعني كان كثير علي
تنزيل على الاعلام العبري صفحه يعني
اسرائيل الرسميه على تويتر نزلت عني تقرير
كامل كثير صحفات عريه نزلت عني ف فكان
وجودي في مجمع الشفاء كان خطر وكذلك نزوح
الى الجنوب كان خطر كمان يعني احلاه مرمون
زي ما بنحكي فلكن صليت استخاره وتوكلت
طربنا قلت اطلع على الجنوب كان موضوع
النزوح من من غزه للجنوب جدا صعب لانه انت
بتمر في في نقطه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مليانه دبابات وجنود وجرافات على طول الخط
فبم النظر بالهويات وانا طبعا ما كان معي
هويه يعني انا طلعت من من البيت في اول
يوم الحرب وسبت هويتي في البيت وما قدرت
اني ارجع اجيبها مره ثانيه لانه انقصف
البيت كله فما كان مش معي هويه ما كانش
معي جواز سفر ما كان معي اي اثبات
للشخصيه فكنت امشي من هالناس والله توكلت
على ربنا قلت يا رب بس انت سهلها معنا
توكلت على ربنا وكان انا قدامي كان ناظر
انه كان يتم استدعاء شباب من الموجودين مع
الناس كان انت ينادوا عليهم ابو البلوزه
الفل كذا ابو الشنطه اه يتم استدعائهم
وانه تعال عننا ويتم اخذهم على جنب
والتحقيق معهم وما بنعرف اذا هو يتم اسرهم
يتم تصفيتهم ما بنعرف شيء فانا كنت ماشي
من هالناس وكنت بس يا رب الطف معنا الحمد
لله ربنا سهلها وعدينا من نقطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وضلينا جايين على الجنوب فكانت
هذه استغرقت الرحله استغرقت
حوالي الست سبع ساعات ماشي اه يعني انا
اخر مره شفت اهلي في 10 10 يعني انا
تقريبا صارلي شهر وشوي قد مش شايف اهلي
حتى اخبار عنهم ما بعرف بتيجي اناعن اخر
اخبر عرفته عنهم قبل اسبوع يعني انا بتبع
الاخبار عشس اعرف انه هم عايشين مستشهدين
حتى انا متجنب التواصل معهم عس انه انا قد
ما اقدر انه انا ما اسبب من خطر الوضع جد
هذا اكثر شي ممكن اخاف منه انا يعني يعني
اي اي اي شخص في هيك حرب بخاف انه في اي
لحظه يجي له خبر استشهاد اهله فانا حتى
وانا في المستشفى كنت كل اسعاف استهداف في
منطقه معينه كل اسعاف اجري عليه بس اشوف
اذا اهلي موجودين ولا مش موجودين ممكن
اكثر شي انا بخاف
منه